bonsoir nouvelle édition du journal de
la rédaction de tv fil 78 voici les
titres de ce mardi 20 janvier 2015
et quand la prison fait office de sas de
radicalisation c'est le parcours de
nombreux terroristes en france nous en
parlerons avec cédric torrès surveillant
à la maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy
secrétaire local de l'ufap unsa justice
le secours populaire des yvelines
multiplie les collectes alimentaires
afin de venir en aide aux familles
reportage sur l'une des opérations
menées récemment afin de lutter contre
la surpopulation des sangliers débattus
sont régulièrement organisés nous étions
aux côtés de l'onef hier matin pour
débuter ce journal direction montigny le
bretonneux où le maire a retiré sa
casquette de président de la communauté
d'agglomération pour ses voeux ce lundi
soir à la ferme du manet des chantiers
sont en cours pour 2015 le point avec
catherine je l'attends à l'occasion de
ses voeux michèle louvier le maire de
montigny devenu président de l'acca ce
qu'il a affirmé ce rôle ne m'éloigne pas
de montigny et je suis toujours aussi
investi pour ma ville son premier propos
a été budgétaire comme nombre de
communes montigny a vu sa dotation
globale de fonctionnement diminué d'un
million d'euros mais cela n'aura pas
d'impact sur les impôts assuré le maire
pas d'augmentation et un niveau
d'investissement égale aux autres années
cette année devrait voir le début de la
construction du pôle culturel bergson
sur le site de l'ancien collège dans le
quartier de lasours de riz un pôle qui
accueillera à terme le conservatoire de
musique l'école de théâtre et le secteur
de musiques amplifiées ainsi que les
écoles de danse les études démarque
également pour la création d'un nouveau
pôle petite enfance en lieu et place de
l'ancienne école sam un autre projet en
2015 les travaux du nouvel établissement
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes débuteront prochainement
dans le parc du château de la coudre dès
que le volet administratif sera
finalisée le pôle gare le quartier saint
quentin sont aussi d'autres chantiers en
cours
un quartier qui se verra doter de
nouvelles caméras de vidéoprotection et
septembre 2015 marquera également la
première rentrée universitaire de
l'estaca une école dédiée à la
conception des transports de demain
les travaux d'élargissement de la route
département
altran claire des 30 à hauteur de
plaisir des buts des perturbations au
niveau de la circulation sont à prévoir
afin de permettre le doublement des
voies mais le principe général est de
maintenir la circulation dans les deux
sens pendant toute la durée des travaux
pour en savoir plus une réunion est
organisée pour la population avec les
élus du secteur rendez vous le 21
janvier à 20 heures au théâtre espace
coluche
le syndicat ufap unsa justice demande
des changements de l'institution
pénitentiaire et de son fonctionnement
suite aux attentats perpétrés en début
d'année et qui met en lumière la
radicalisation religieuse de certains
détenus bonsoir cédric torrès
vous êtes le secrétaire local de l'ufap
unsa surveillant à la maison d'arrêt de
bois d'arcy pour débuter j'aimerais
savoir comment ça s'est déroulé dans
votre maison pénitentiaire dans votre
établissement pénitentiaire sur bois
d'arcy à ces événements les attentats et
puis ensuite les minutes de silence la
mobilisation contre les terroristes
comment ça a été vécue dans votre
établissement par les détenus
alors le mercredi le jour des attentats
on a entendu des détenus
par simple provocation en mon sens et je
pense qu'au sens de beaucoup de monde
dans l'établissement cria l'avoir bas et
et d'autre le mercredi en tout cas
d'accord et ensuite ils ont eu du mal à
respecter cette minute de silence
sinon nous expliquer oui en fait mais
c'est toujours pareil c'est par
provocation et c'est des études qui
taper aux portes comme tout nous on
faisait la minute de silence en
détention lui taper aux portes de façon
violente pour montrer qu'ils étaient là
que il voulait absolument nous gêner
dans notre minute de silence parce qu'il
fallait que c'est une obligation mais
s'appelle libérer la parole justement on
prêtait des tenues de ceux qui se
radicalise alors la difficulté la
difficulté au sein des établissements si
difficile de repérer une radicalisation
d'une personne d'une personne parce que
vous avez tout simplement un exemple
vous avez environ 800 à 850 détenus à
bois d'arcy pour 500 places donc déjà
pour trouver
vous avez des cellules de feu carré sur
une mission de trois ans cellule et puis
le personnel est tabou fatigué parce que
vous avez il manque 40 entre 40 et 50
personnes à la bonne heure si
aujourd'hui donc c'est pas rien pour
l'établissement de cette taille mais on
n'est pas les seuls dans ce cas là sur
la région de paris mais voilà on est
tous
vous avez un agent qui fait 60 heures
supplémentaires par mois en moyenne donc
c'est difficile et les normes telles
soit dans la radicalisation pour autant
les autres syndicats s'inquiètent depuis
plusieurs années déjà cette
radicalisation pardon globalement dans
les prisons le durcissement des modes de
pensée de la religion c'est pas un
phénomène nouveau là on en parle
beaucoup forcément avec les attentats
mais vous l'avez déjà constatée depuis
de nombreuses années de la
radicalisation il existe depuis je vais
me dire jusqu'il ya 20 ans dans les
années 90 on avait peut-être une
radicalisation qui était beaucoup moins
importante mais nous on a quand même
demandé on me demandait quand même une
construction de la construction
d'établissements spécifique par rapport
à la dangerosité des bus des détenus
parce qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'au
moment donné parce qu'on est acteur du
tien et qu'on est présent sur le terrain
avec nos collègues et qu'on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait des détenus qui
étaient dangereux qui ne pouvait pas
être mis avec d'autres donc même si on
parle pas de radicalisation on parle de
même phénomène
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que au
mois de janvier 2015 qui certes il ya eu
les attentats et c'est malheureux et je
trouve ça scandaleux ce qui s'est passé
mais on pointe du doigt la
radicalisation des prisons c'est pas
nouveau
alors maintenant ils sont pas tous
passés par ce phénomène de prison ils
sont une minorité qui est passé on
parlait d'un ou voire des deux
sur trois mais il existe ça fait des
années et des années qu'on le dénonce
qu'on le dit qu' il faut recruter des
imams parce qu'eux aussi sont importants
parce que par exemple du momment de bois
d'arcy qui vient bonheur si un langage
très tolérant d'ailleurs il est
reprendre quand certains font des
bêtises en détention et comment ça se
passe justement pour un musulman qui
veut pratiquer sa religion une fois en
prison
un imam qui vient régulièrement et
viennent et où les habilités de prier
comme comment ça se passe
alors l'imam ils viennent tous les
vendredis pour faire le culte musulman
dont qui vient bien souvent ils
demandent à ces jeunes moins jeunes de
respecter la règle de la république mais
c'est pas ceux qui viennent au culte
musulman qui se radicalise c'est pas
cela c'est ce qu'ils sont qui est en
cellule qui n'ont pas forcément un
comportement agressif qui sont comme qui
n'en veulent pas la société parce que
ils pensent la plupart la plupart des
jeunes qui sont
en veulent à la société à la république
parce que tout est désormais en prison
mais souvent y viennent parce qu'ils ont
fait une petite bêtise ou une grosse
bêtise mais ils ont ce phénomène là donc
déjà dit ce qu'est ce qu'ils font ils
ont juste appuyer sur le bouton de dire
on est une voie la france à tapas elle
t'a pas aidé donc rien que ça vous avez
une écoute et donc déjà les jeunes les
jeunes et moins jeunes parce qu'il n'ya
pas que les plus jeunes qui sont
radicalisés mais comment la voie des
jihadistes est porté à l'intérieur des
prisons
comment le message est véhiculé dans les
prisons alors on est ce problème de
communication par internet les
communications par téléphone parce que
malheureusement les téléphones en
cellule on a on a une gouvernement qui
qui a voté l'article 55 de la loi
pénitentiaire qui interdit la fouille
systématique après l'entrée à la sortie
après les parloirs entre autres sauf
qu'aujourd'hui
or certes ça rende pas plus pour une pas
moins on ne sait pas personne ne sait en
tout cas il est sûr d'une chose c'est
que au lieu de se prémunir de batailler
sur une loi avait deux sur un article de
loi de ce type
il aurait mieux valu peut-être accentuée
sur je sais pas moi embaucher du
personnel parce que on manque de
personnel
vc les moyens le ministère à
l'administration pénitentiaire de
travailler et de pouvoir acheter des
caméras du matériel et aujourd'hui c'est
pas possible
la difficulté financière sont telles que
même pour remplacer une caméra c'est
compliqué mais c'est compliqué faut
passer par une plate forme il faut
déterminer que c'est possible c'est pas
possible que la validité il faut valider
enfin on est en train de s'empêtrer dans
une administration dans des charges
administratives qui bloque tout qui
bloque tout aujourd'hui on a des
établissements qui sont fin d'année 2014
par exemple il a été difficile il était
difficile d'avoir ne serait-ce que c'est
peut-être gros ce que veut dire mais un
stylo il fallut pleurer pour aussi on
arrive là par en revenir à la question
de la radicalisation vous nous dites
c'est difficile parce qu'il manque du
personnel pour détecter néanmoins malgré
tout comment on peut détecter
vous qui êtes surveillants comment vous
repérer ceux qui peuvent se radicalise
et qu'ils ne viennent pas forcément sur
les rendez vous avec les imams par
exemple vous nous dites ils restent dans
leur cellule ça c'est un facteur qui
vous alerte comment vous voulez détecter
vous
alertée ensuite alors au même titre au
même titre que par exemple la prévention
du suicide ou au même titre que tout ça
comme tout vous avez un détenu qui est
en souffrance vous l'aurez détectée mais
vous le détecte quand vous arrivez que
vous êtes primo affectés je parle pour
les surveillants qui sont stagiaires qui
arrive qu'ils font ce qu'ils peuvent
avec les arbres qu'on leur donne à
l'école une formation qui à mon sens
devrait être peut-être accentuée sur le
problème de radicalisation de promotion
du sud parce que tout ça c'est une
détection de problèmes par personnel des
détenus c'est bon ils ont le choc
carcéral enfin tout ça mais le
surveillant qui vient d'arriver à
produire si par exemple vous avez les
douches qui sont pas en cellule qu'on
travaille à d'autres établissements
mais les jeunes qui viennent est arrivé
qu'est ce qu'ils font mais ils ont été
d'un idiot il pense à l'organisation
parce que bon pendant un an vi aux
stagiaires donc qu'il pense être
titulaire pour pouvoir être parce qu'une
fois qu'ils sont titulaires ils sont
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui et vous avez
des gens mais voilà donc on leur demande
des tâches administratives
j'ai entendu aujourd'hui dans la
formation il n'y a pas de formation pour
détecter la radicalisation lacération au
suicide et ou comment ça c'est hyper
compliqué parce que je pense que tout
personne aujourd'hui ne sait comment
faire pour détecter des tubes qui se
radicalise aujourd'hui la question c'est
à se poser la question qui doit être
posée mais concrètement c'est comment
fait-on vous tous mais comment un autre
des tubes radicaliser un autre détenu si
la question c'est comment quel est le
phénomène le processus pour pour dire à
un jeune tu vas aller mon expression
mais tu va les tuer
tu vas tu va servir de bombes humaines
comment on fait comment font-ils
et je pense que personne aujourd'hui ne
le sait le faire maintenant est ce que
c'est pas le même processeur que le
processus que dans les années 90 pour
une des sectes est-ce que c'est pas le
même processus de processus est ce qu on
n'a pas ça ces questions là qu'il faut
se poser est la formation à l'énap avec
l'école nationale d'administration
pénitentiaire âge elle est ce qu'elle
est je dis pas qu'elle est mauvaise je
dis pas qu'elle est bonne je dis qu'elle
est ce qu'elle est mais je pense qu'il
va peut-être falloir augmenter peut-être
la durée de formation pour pouvoir
mettre ce problème et éventuellement
pouvoir faire détecter aux gens un
premier centre
des symptômes et lorsque vous entendez
le gouvernement évoqué des moyens
nouveaux débloquer des quartiers
spécifiques créés pour justement
incarcéré est ce ce type de détenus qui
se radicalise
vous trouvez que ça va dans le bon sens
alors incarcéré croyez aussi et alors le
problème c'est incarcérés des détenus
des détenus par exemple ça se passe à
fresnes ils sont vingt ils sont une
vingtaine je crois à fresnes ça se passe
bien mais parce qu'ils sont qu'une
vingtaine
mais demain vous avez on parle des
centaines voire de milliers de jeunes
qui sont partis faire le djihad en syrie
ou en irak
on les met où clairement on l'aimé où on
va pouvoir
ou alors il faut créer des
établissements mais mais c'est pareil
alors la voici au système guantanamo
est ce que c'est la bonne solution je
sais pas ça veut dire qu'on l'aimé on
les enferme et puis on jette la clé
c'est peut-être pas le bayer s'est
peut-être se poser la question en amont
ceux qui sont déjà radicaliser on s'en
occupe mais il faut peut-être prévenir
ces mais ça c'est pas nous c'est pas le
boulot de la prison c'est le boulot du
gouvernement de prendre des bonnes
décisions et une bonne fois pour toutes
de prendre des décisions car vous
attendez quoi vous concrètement
aujourd'hui en tant que surveillant
pénitentiaire mais de savoir comment à
quelle sauce on va être mangé c'est
surtout ça parce que là qui sont tous en
train de faire des annonces on parle de
il faut retirer la carte d'identité aux
gens qui vont faire le djihad là-bas on
parle de les enfermer on m'a fait
arrêter tout et puis prenez des
décisions
on vous dira et puis surtout peut-être
écouté le personnel que si qui sur le
terrain qui quitte en souffrance qui
y a du mal à travailler parce que mais
ils sont su qu'on les établissements
surpeuplés
il faut trouver des solutions concrètes
pour qu'on puisse travailler tout
simplement parce qu'il ya déjà et puis
surtout il ya des gens qui n'ont rien à
faire en prison ferme en ce sens il ya
des gens et des peines quand on conduit
sans permis
peut-être faire faire des peines
alternatives à ces gens là plutôt que le
mettre en prison et 2 il est là
justement peut côtoyer des détenus qui
sont peut-être déjà dix finales qui sont
peut-être radicaux donc donc tout ça
fait tout ça c'est lié tout ait lieu
juste pour conclure cet entretien vous
nous parler depuis tout à l'heure aussi
du mal être des surveillants prison des
difficultés qui sont rencontrés vous
avez le sentiment de ne pas être entendu
aujourd'hui ne pas être écoutés qu'on ne
nous apporte pas de réponse de solutions
concrètes au delà de ce problème de
radicalisation au delà de mais
concrètement on demande alors on va
demander à un personnel de surveillance
de faire d'être assistant social à son
honneur d'être psychologue fin de
d'avoir plusieurs casquettes
ok on travaille avec de l'humain on est
là le problème c'est que comme tous
savent l établissement comme celui de
bois d'arcy où vous avez une
surpopulation qui et c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui et que rien n'est fait
baudard si par exemple vous avez pas eu
de chance et l'uil vous savez pas de
choix d'un cellule donc sa part demain
on met les douches en cellule à bois
d'arcy vous avez 95 % des tensions qui
sont apaisées ça simplifierait le
travail au quotidien l'organe est petit
ça permettrait de faire un travail
cohérent sur la détection et huile qui
vont des radicaux de tout ça mais ça il
faut y mettre les moyens aujourd'hui on
a l'impression que
l'argent par ailleurs on réduit le
budget des ministères la justice de
l'initiation pays d'un tiers pour le
mettre ailleurs
ouais mais faut peut-être falloir on est
pas on n'est pas des établissements où
on met tout en l'air la porte on ferme
la porte on jette la clé non il faut
qu'on travaille il faut quand il faut
les réinsérer puis les études qui sont
déjà dit c'est moi je veux bien et m on
veut y mettre à l'isolément déjà l'avoir
créé des spas d'isolement parce qu'on en
a pas assez
et puis après on a fait quoi on les a
enfermés me fait voir où j'ai attaqué
puis non il faut qu on puisse trouver
des solutions pour pouvoir travailler
avec eux pour leur expliquer que et puis
il faut recruter des imams aussi il faut
il faut occulter les omis des homonymes
musulmans parce que eux sont importants
aujourd'hui alors il ya des choses sur
lesquelles il faudra mettre des règles
mais il faut qu'il soit recruté parce
que on a besoin de plus de plus plus de
personnes qui sont qui sont tolérants et
la plupart des musulmans qui sont en
prison ne sont pas radicaux au contraire
même certains ont certainement dénoncer
mais dans les faits de masse de ceux qui
voulait stigmatiser la république en
disant c'est votre faute si on est en
prison
ils sont pas ils se sont pas manifestés
qui vont s'écrire difficile d'avoir un
discours comme ça on verra donc si les
moyens si les annonces vont être suivis
de moyens ce sera rapidement dans les
prochains jours on imagine de la part du
gouvernement verra si vous avez été
entendu en tout cas merci à cédric
torrès secrétaire local ufap unsa
surveillants également la maison d'arrêt
de bois d'arcy la suite de ce journal
c'est avec le secours populaire des
yvelines qui soutient environ 2000
familles en leur distribuant des
produits alimentaires de première
nécessité une opération de collecte a
lieu ce week end une autre se déroulera
encore samedi prochain 4 nuls à temps
dans les yvelines le secours populaire
français aident actuellement sur le plan
alimentaire 2000 familles tout au long
de l'année
pour cela des collectes de produits non
périssables sont organisées
c'était le cas ce samedi dans un
supermarché près de magny les hameaux
les bénévoles distribuent aux clients
des petites fiches sur lesquelles sont
inscrits les produits souhaités lait
farine riz pâtes ou encore conserve on
est bien fourni en pâte déjà
épatant général les gens c'est ce qu'ils
achètent de façon systématique mais on
va pas crier on va pas refuser n'est pas
parce que les gens ont toujours besoin
mais c'est vrai que on est bien fourni
en parle ce qui nous manque souvent
c'est le chocolat le café des produits
le lait le là c'est un produit qui me
manque beaucoup
parmi ses clients 20 jours karine pour l
aider l'association c'est tout
simplement normal j'étais venu vraiment
des vannages chercher une plaquette de
beurre et donc comme il était là j'ai
fait des courses un peu plus important
je sais qu'il ya des gens qui sont dans
le besoin
enfin je connais plein de personnes qui
sont bénévoles aussi à l'association
ça me paraît normal demande voilà il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont dans le besoin
et il ya beaucoup de familles isolées
fameux famille de parents l'antenne de
magny les hameaux soutient ainsi une
cinquantaine de familles les produits
collectés ce samedi seront distribués à
la fin du mois le secours populaire
organise une autre opération le 27
janvier notamment dans les magasins
partenaires à elancourt versailles ou
encore villepreux tout autre sujet à
présent les sangliers les chevreuils et
qui sont parfois en grand nombre dans
nos forêts lors surpeuplement entraîne
des dégradations dans les forêts sur les
routes mais aussi dans les différentes
propriétés pour réguler cette population
l'office national des forêts organise
débattu nous avons participé à l'une
d'entre elle mélanie poquet et william
bell pour les images
on rappelle donc un comme ça joue en
conseil de sécurité on se déplace dans
les véhicules donc avec les armes dans
les housses entre les battues les armes
doivent décharger cassé pour les express
vous respectez les angles de tir ou
tirer tout animal sorti d'un tract en
respectant les 30 degrés vous aurez
aussi droit tiré sur le devant à très
courte distance 1 20-25 mètres maximum à
et à condition que la trace ou dilatera
qu'ils soient bien évidemment loin
ils sont 24 chasseurs à être là en forêt
de port-royal 24 avoir répondu à l'appel
de l'office national des forêts
parce que ce matin la chasse est un peu
particulière leur objectif abattre
sangliers et chevreuils présent en trop
grand nombre pour le chevreuil les
chasseurs ne peuvent pas dépasser le
nombre de 27 sur la saison pour le
sanglier c'est une toute autre histoire
expédia pas de limitation nous ce que
l'on cherche à éliminer
c'est le maximum de d'animaux parce
qu'on sait pertinemment que de toute
façon on n'arrivera pas à éradiquer de
cet animal il se reproduit très vite il
peut mettre bas jusqu'à 10 à 20 animaux
failli maire est nommé par par saison
par année sachant qu'il ya plusieurs
mises bas par an les chasseurs se
répartissent en groupe
les tireurs seront 15 avec à leur tête
des responsables
les chefs de lille je vais chef de ligne
donc je vais m'occuper d'une ligne de
poster le tout c'est de fermer une
enceinte donc là en l'occurrence
réformer le carré de la belle toise nous
allons mettre trois lignes de miradors
donc les miradors c'est pour tyr en
sécurité en les gens ont respecté un
certain nombre de l'angle de tir est
donc là moi je vais poster 4 5 personnes
sur leurs miradors alignés ont
expliquant où ils doivent tirer ou pas
le mirador celle aux élèves qu'ils
imposent pour des questions de sécurité
les chasseurs tirent en direction du sol
si le tir n'atteint pas l'animal la
balle sans terre et toujours pour la
sécurité mais aussi par souci de
propreté
les douilles doivent être ramassés les
traqueurs sont au nombre de neuf avec
leurs chiens ils sont chargés de
rabattre les animer
ces chasseurs sont armés mais ne tire
pas de la sécurité de nos chiens et
aussi pour nous aussi pour nous est ce
que on sait jamais trop la réaction
kouame sûr surtout pour protéger nos
charges dano noah masson avons pas de
charge et c'est vraiment au cas où c'est
tout tous les traqueurs tout le temps
c'est tout le temps comme ça nous on ne
tire pas on ne tire pas dans une traque
et ce volet
on vient sonner le début de traque donc
normalement tout le monde les poster
savent que la charge vient de démarrer
deux coups de corne
c'est pour signaler un chevreuil 3 un
sanglier
on y est
quelques minutes à peine après le début
de la traque le premier animal et
débusquer
celui ci pèse près de 80 kg sur cette
journée les chasseurs ont abattu trois
sangliers et un chevreuil chaque bête
fait l'objet d'une fiche de signalement
que récupère l'eau à 9 sur le massif de
trappes la chasse se pratique sur cinq
journées de novembre à février
la prochaine battue aura lieu lundi
prochain sport à présent le badminton en
double est une discipline qui demande
technique automatismes et beaucoup
d'écouté également portrait de deux
jeunes joueurs du club des longs cours
qui évoluent ensemble depuis maintenant
10 ans particularité ils sont en couple
dans la vie comme sur les terrains
mélanie poquet
l'écoutent la communication principales
qualités à avoir pour jouer en double de
quoi peut-être en tirer avantage quand
on est en couple dans la vie allah is et
jean-louis jouent ensemble depuis deux
ans on a compté six mêmes par le regard
on peut plus passer dans savoir la
personne si elle se sent bien on
apprendra moins besoin de cette rue pour
se comprendre dans ces raids aussi mais
dans les deux sens en fait parce que
s'il ya quelqu'un qui est le super lot
enfin on voit tout de suite son visage
et donc du coup ça peut déstabiliser
c'est un avantage comme un inconvénient
en double mixte
les rôles sont bien définis la fille
joue principalement au filet pour mettre
la pression
tandis que l'homme court le fond du
terrain âgés de 25 et 27 ans à nice et
jean louis se sont rencontrés lors d'un
tournoi si ce jour là ils évoluent
ensemble ce n'est pas toujours le cas en
moins sauf que certains qui ont fait un
ou deux tournois par an ça va mais bon
faut pas voir en partenaire fixe en
couple parce que vaut pas que le
problème du quotidien deviennent ont
altéré dans
dans le jeu où on peut le faire si on
suit à des désaccords sur le jeu que ça
entraîne pas de problème dans la vie de
couple moi j'ai plutôt envie jouer elle
fait du coup effectivement comme
compagne dans la vie j'ai envie de
partager aussi en fait un jeune c'est un
sport qui nous a rapprochés
quelque chose qui prend ainsi le prend
pas mal de temps et à l'akwaba c'est un
sport qu'on aime beaucoup et ça joue
aussi pas mal sur la complicité je
trouvais d'autant plus sont mixtes si le
couple permet une compréhension plus
rapide sur le terrain c'est aussi le cas
pour des partenaires qui pratique depuis
longtemps ensemble
mais en tant que coupe il faut aussi
savoir faire la part des choses ont
collé des amis qui ne sont que les amis
non oui parfois on peut voir un mondial
c'est déconseillé mais on peut trouver
certains couples certains de très bien
d'autres qui vraiment ont arrêté de
jouer ensemble ce match là anaïs et
gendres ils ont perdu la bonne humeur
est toujours présente mais le débrief il
n'est pas encore fait enfin du journal
je vous retrouve demain pour une
nouvelle édition tout de suite 7 8
sociétés préparé par catherine zola tôt
avec ses invités il sera question du
vélodrome nationale un nom après son
ouverture quelles sont les pistes pour
son développement
très bonne soirée